olympic figure skater getting slammed on
chinese social media nineteen-year-old
zhu yi crushed crash rather into a wall
during sunday's short program in the
team event the california native gave up
her u.s citizenship to compete for china
at the winter games chyna finished in
fifth place after her poor performance
and zhu yi has fallen became the top
trending topic on weibo that's the
chinese equivalent of twitter some
critics there called her a disgrace
others mocked her for not being fluent
in chinese in an interview after her
program zhu reportedly said she was
upset and a little embarrassed she said
i just really wanted to show them what i
was able to do but unfortunately i did
well that's slammed
you know you're an athlete you are just
trying to do your best that's what we
tell athletes just you know win but do
your best and to have people attack you
you know she feels badly enough of
course because you know she knows how to
do the move otherwise she wouldn't have
been there right so the fact that it
didn't work out for her to get harassed
that was awful i wonder if she regrets
renouncing the u.s citizenship to go to
china well so here's the thing i mean
mom is chinese uh both of her parents
are chinese i i
in the us you compete for yourself but
also for your country country but in a
lot of other countries sports really is
the national totem yeah and so the
pressure of being an athlete for a
country right before a billion people
it's got to be able to she's half
american and have chinese is that why
she can she
is of chinese ancestry was born in the
united states she doesn't have duelists
she actually gave up her u.s citizenship
to become a chinese citizen you have to
be a citizen of the country to compete
wow yeah good job i'll say that yes
exactly well done julian came up short
well good job
but you did a great job we appreciate
that